here's the benefit of being a childless
woman this is the day in the life of a
childless woman watch this
in the life of a childless woman I wake
up at 6am I remember that I have no kids
to take to school so I take an edible
masturbate and go back to sleep I wake
up at 12 30 pm and get ready for a busy
day of doing whatever the [__] I feel
like I put on my most impractical and
stylish shoes since I won't be chasing a
child around the grocery store I go to
my fav spot in Paris to grab a croissant
I do a meditation sesh on the plane
since I have no screaming kids allowing
me all the Time in the World to become
enlightened the weightlessness of my
existence has granted me superhuman
Powers I teleport myself back home then
I get ready for a night out with
whatever hot guy I met on Raya that
morning I call up a babysitter and tell
her that I don't need her since I still
don't have kids now it's time for a
workout so I hit Mount Everest for a
quick climb I invent a time machine go
back and time and kill Hitler crazy
bastard it's amazing what you can do
when you have this much free time and
that's a day in the life of a childless
woman she looks unhappy well she doesn't
have a job either
right I mean I just got triggered but
but Jimmy Pat from you guys watching
Adam I think she's really sad like she
she doesn't look that smile isn't like a
real I felt the same way do you feel
that yeah
she looks like she's hurting yes let me
tell you one thing wow I agree with one
thing she did in that entire [__]
video she went back and killed Hitler
okay good for you yeah that's good let
me tell you the problem with ladies like
this by the way can we just pull up for
age real quick I'm guessing late 40s um
no what did you say I wasn't safe I'm
guessing 41 ish 52. what do we got give
me an age 52. she's 47. all right so I
was off by a year here's the problem
a few years ago when she was 42 43 and
she kind of still had her looks and she
was allegedly banging 50 Cent and
this this Sex in the City I do what I
want to do I could go where I want to go
that was cute
when you're 50 and no dude this hot dude
you meet on Raya they're not gonna exist
any any more of you Chelsea
period and the problem is this it's like
for every one Chelsea Handler that
thinks this way yeah there's a million
50 year old women that were fed this
[__] that are like [__] you Chelsea
Handler for me and for indoctrinating me
I watch sex in the city I was told I
don't need no man I was told that I can
just do what I want to do and Gallivan
off to Paris and jerk off in the middle
of the day and have fun and have my wine
it's like let me tell you what's going
to end up with those women at the end of
the day they're going to be uh
non-married no kids 17 cats 14 dildos a
couple different vibrators and sad A F
this is not a good business model for
you to live your life off of foreign
yes yeah but but and I mean and I get it
Jimmy we get this is it's a comedy she's
being funny and stuff but I see real
pain and there's something missing I
also felt pain I felt painful I did it
her smile it was like I was like a
hostage video yeah because imagine she's
she's gonna be 50 something yeah she's
gonna have the cats and all that stuff
but I mean I think I think deep down
inside you want to have some kids I
think I would like to have I didn't have
kids so I missed that when I was
supposed to have kids I was doing comedy
and then I got not too late for you
Jimmy oh it is you wanna you wanna adopt
Vinnie take Vinnie it is too but but I
don't have any so I was I would like to
I was thinking of adopting right because
you want to have someone to bury you and
uh that's the number one reason and the
number one doesn't have anybody to bury
me should be that's hilar I mean it's
sad but it's hilarious Pat why did you
show this video of all things we could
be discussing today UFOs flying saucers
everything at train wrecks everything
China what made you go with this Chelsea
Handler glad I mean we've been talking
about this what a waste of a life yeah
what a waste of a life and you know for
somebody that buys into that life a
miserable lonely life everything in life
to me that has value is stuff that
outlives me and it's great relationships
and that takes a long time time that
takes a very very long time again if
you've been through the fast life and
you've gone through it where it's like
another one and another one and another
one and you and I were having this
conversation regularly where I'm like
look how many more you want to do you
know how many more you want to go
through you know what else are you going
to be doing this is a hero to who I mean
you know what that reminded me of is
when I wanted to have a kid and I was
talking to my wife about
um adopting and I just kept having the
same you know idea in my head was the
reason why I want to have a kid is
because I want to stop thinking about
myself 24 hours a day I'd like to put my
energy into loving something else and
building something else up and that's
she was I mean of course it's a comedy
sketch yeah we got that yeah but um you
know that seems like the opposite of
that so just think about it's just
that's the problem I think I'm
experiencing with not having kids is I
spend too much time thinking about
myself I'll give you a complete opposite
side for you to be thinking about okay
thank God she didn't have any kids okay
because the world would have two or
three more Chelsea handlers okay
I don't disagree but here's the part as
well I think too many of the uh we
talked about this on the last podcast I
think I was in Orlando yesterday and in
Vegas yesterday I gave a talk in Orlando
and I gave a talk in Vegas and then I
flew back last night
and the group I spoke to in Orlando in
in Vegas my message was about some of
you guys got to choose to start having
four five six seven eight kids not just
one or two I'm dead serious with you I'm
telling you I think the right parents
need to have more kids a man named John
Morris who was our chair at vistage in
La great guy powerful guy in people know
him in Santa Monica money guy venture
capital guy and he was our Mentor he was
60 at the time give or take and
one day I'm having a conversation with
them I'd have my monthly one-on-ones
with them and I said hey John how many
kids you got he says two I said wow why
two you know you think you made the
right choice with two he says biggest
mistake of my life I said really two
kids biggest mistake it's his biggest
mistake of my life and so why is that he
says the moment
I got good
at being a parent I stopped having kids
tell me what thing in life do you stop
doing after you become great at it
biggest mistake we should have had four
more kids
you got me thinking I came home I sold
that I told that to Jen my idea was I
want to have five to ten kids is what I
wanted have we ended up with four we
were supposed to have five twins good
you know one didn't make it but you know
God's blessed us in a great way and life
is irregular Alec Baldwin huh regular
Alec Baldwin is that what it is he's got
like seven kids now oh dude I won't have
20 kids I'm telling you right now I
would have 20 kids if I if I had them my
way but you know it's it's it's a
different life but also at the same time
there's a part where it's like good for
you for not having one because let's
just say if she did have a kid she
probably would do it out of wedlock and
she would probably sell the same exact
philosophies to her and that kid's
probably going to be living the same
exact life as well as she is and doing
what she's doing so I don't know uh this
message unfortunately is going to
inspire some people for every Andrew
Tate you have to have a Chelsea Handler
you the extreme arguments of both sides
let them hash it out and debate it and
then see who's going to come up you know
long-term winning I don't know can I add
to that with the entertainment number
one I don't think this is breaking news
ironically Andrew Tate does have kids
yeah okay so like he does he and he's
advocating having kids so here's the
problem I have with this can you imagine
if some dude was like yep not having
kids just could meet him just pouring in
on the [__] y'all just I'm out there
making my money no kids no wife I'm just
driving my cars I don't want no kid
weighing me down I'm going to Paris I'm
having fun I'm jerking off all day
saying that as a guy dude you just got
canceled what are you talking about what
are you saying right now no guy could
say what she's saying and here's the
harm with Chelsea
can't say that yeah Vinnie you go out
and say that unless yeah cancel I'm
finished here's the problem with Chelsea
for everyone Chelsea's uh Handler
that does this for attention clearly
it's not like she's saying in this in
the mirror every day and she's got 10
and a half million views on Twitter
freak Show yeah but for every one
Chelsea's Handler doing this to get
views there's a lady named Debbie in
Ohio that's like yeah you tell him
Chelsea and there's a lady named Maggie
in Florida and Rebecca in California
that's living that life and they're
crying on the inside because they're
living Chelsea's life that's
romanticized of being just this selfish
individual succumbing to all your
individual needs well it's not
attractive when a guy does it that's why
that guy doesn't come around
gallivanting like this and it's even
less attractive when a woman does it I
maybe maybe I was projecting on to her
who knows like maybe you know I sent her
smile didn't look real maybe it is real
and maybe I'm projecting because I feel
bad about myself not having kids but
Jimmy maybe that's a good chance that's
cool when you're a lady and you say that
when you're 25. and it's kind of cool
when you're 35. not when you're nearly
50. it's sad and disgusting here's
here's the part that all of us have to
deal with and and we have this
conversation with our uh the guy that we
love the world loves uh not broken or
some friend no micro
was here I'm thinking of handsome man
and by the way micro you know saying 60
never married never never had kids never
heard never and that good looking of a
guy like he is like an all-around
American guy that you know a girl would
want to be with
uh too straight he's straight I think
he's straight I I would have to say he
is straight I don't I don't know
personally but I would say he is
straight okay you know the one
conversation we had at the end of the
video this is like a straight guy there
you go impressive
here's the part here's the part
we're all sales people when somebody
tells me I can't sell I've never been
good in sales [__] you've been
selling for your entire life on whatever
the lies you believe in or whatever the
truths you believe in your sales person
okay you can sell anything you want to
other people as if you're happy with the
decision you made but then you have to
be by yourself and when you're by
yourself only one person knows if you're
happy with the decision you made
Chelsea's selling that life but by the
way if she's by herself she's a hundred
percent fully happy with the decisions
she made guess what more power to you
I'm just not convinced she is so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
thank you
[Music]